let's bring reggie miller into the  conversation off of that conversation  you had with stephen curry and i know  that happened just before the season  began correct reggie so you're right you  had no idea at that point that you guys  would be teammates on this night huh  you made it hey  great greatest ever  congratulations  [Laughter]  rachel you're wrong you're on the list  man  whoa  [Applause]  seriously i  [Music]  okay  wow um  [Music]  i'm a little flustered right now because  we all know this is very subjective and  i look at that list because you're gonna  get into who didn't make the list and  uh  there's great players on this list and  looking at the first 50  everyone absolutely deserves to be on  that list and i wasn't going to be  upset if i wasn't  because i would put my resume up against  anyone  um but who's on that list right now they  absolutely i'm uh i'm a little  shaken right now all right because i  wasn't expecting to be on that list